I used to live my life a quarter mile at
a time but things changed my father now
I will always be in your heart
little Brian I have a gift for you your
daddy gave me this no I'm gonna give it
to you it's very special it's for
protection from what's coming
all right down what's next no matter how
fast you walk
I am not to be compared to you know not
rugs or pasture and barn
just caught up to me there's a long time
down so we're up against a master thief
fasten high-performance driver
Oh easy
Jacob is Tom's brother your whole life
you pushed yourself to be faster than
Donna smarter than down stronger than
time but could you kill him
because I'm ready if you are there's
nothing more powerful than the love of
family you turn that into anger there's
nothing more dangerous maybe this is the
end but we don't go out together you
know I'd ride to the death with you
[Music]
it's good to work please tell me that's
not a pontiac fiero
strapped through a rocket engine
impressive I no no no that's that's not
impressed
I came here to take you down a little
cause that's your mistake
this is my world
damn they got a magnet plane hold on
tell me you're not thinking what I think
you're thinking there's no bridge
oh hell no
[Music]
hey guys
surprise nice Clubhouse
[Music]